[Music]
from the same Rider as Heathers and
Batman Returns and the director of this
and only this because how could you top
it come Sylvester Stallone's best
dystopian action comedy since the one
that started his career Italian Stallion
rated X
Demolition Man
travel to the 2030s a conservative's
dream of the future liberals wand you
are an incredibly sensitive man who
inspires joy joy feelings in all those
around you Sylvester Stallone is the
Demolition Man John Spartan an LA cop
with a reputation for blowing things up
like I said an LA cop LAPD Chief Michael
Moore said sorry for the botched
detonation
when he sent to cryo prison for a crime
he did commit the future will turn to
this unfrozen caveman detective to bring
his rival to Justice because in the
Ironclad logic of movies it takes crazy
to fight crazy send a maniac to
catchment Simon Phoenix is an
old-fashioned criminal we need an
old-fashioned cop I'm not sure he's any
different than Simon Phoenix himself
send the maniac to catch a maniac hey
you used that one already
Wesley Snipes is Simon Phoenix
what the [ __ ] is that thing you are
buying one credit for a violation of the
purple
I can't say what about
holy YouTube would fit right in and
Demolition Man
ah Wesley blade Trinity Snipes is Simon
Phoenix a super power terrorist so over
the top he gave Dennis Rodman whatever
his whole deal was Dennis goes to San
Antonio and then Demolition Man comes
out and he changes his hair color did
you know they offered the role to Jackie
Chan first that would have been
different
I also never play that clip again Sandra
Bullock shines in a breakthrough role as
Huxley she's an adorable little
sociopath her doing battle with that
strangely weapon scrapped in those
roundhouse quickly look this isn't a
wild west okay hurting people's not a
good thing who learned all of her
English from watching porn you really
licked his ass
and Dennis Leary steals the show as
every bumper sticker on the back of a
lifted pickup truck in a Bass Pro Shop
parking lot I want to eat bacon and
butter and buckets of cheese okay I want
to smoke two bits of God the size of
Cincinnati in a non-smoking section I
want to run through the streets naked
with green Jello all over my body yeah
this guy is definitely not faxed even
after AIDS got its own Multiverse after
AIDS there was NRS after NRS there was
ubt so travel to a horrifying vision of
the future not because it's oppressive
that's every dystopia no because
everyone is basic
the dogs
in one of the few R-rated action sci-fi
films that's remembered more for its
clever writing than its shootouts but
kids today will never understand the
significance of this movie just like my
ex-wife will never understand the
significance of the John Spartan
mannequin I bought from a Planet
Hollywood estate sale
it's it's beautiful
starring time cop Blade Runner 2032 she
smells seashells elrond Dullard I want
him bound not tomorrow not after
breakfast now Law and Order San Angelos
Dennis the Menace Bob the minion and
Netflix Executives Jeffrey Dahmer I'm
jacked to the Future
how's that damn three seashell thing
work okay three seashells time my first
theory is that it's just a bidet control
show one adjust the aim shell two for
water pressure shell three for hot or
cold Theory two is that everyone plugs
or simply scrapes their butts with the
seashells and throws them down the
toilet when they're full this is
supported by a 2006 interview with
Stallone and does explain the presence
of the Chrome plunger-like device to the
right of the toilet likely for ramming
the use shells down the drain a
complicating factor for these theories
however is the presence of the scraps
community in the LA sewer system these
are densely populated neighborhoods
large enough to support multiple food
vendors inside what used to be San
Angelo's sewer meaning that the largest
sewage and water mains of the city are
no longer required for human waste hoop
doesn't appear to even make it
underground in this future leading Simon
Phoenix to remark on the underground's
comforting home-cooked smell love that
smell
so where does the poop of San Angelos go
how do the three seashells really work
Demolition Man remains intentionally
obscure on those questions bringing me
to my third and I believe most
thematically consistent Theory nobody
knows how the three seashells work in
universe or out and they're all too
ashamed and repressed to ask each other
for help just listen to Rob Schneider's
reaction here he doesn't know how to use
the three seashells
now is that the life of a man who knows
how the 3C shells work no the Sandra
Bullock a student of our era and way of
life give John even the most basic
knowledge of how to use the toilet no
why because she doesn't know either no
one knows they're all fumbling around in
their shared secret shame that's why
they never touch each other they all
have doodoo hands Theory four every
restaurant is Taco Bell so all they do
is pee out their butthole anyway
bread puns happen when you yeast expect
them The Best is Yet to crumb I went to
a fight last night and a hockey game
broke out well that's just like your
opinion man I recorded this voice over
while riding a horse on my Montana Ranch